then we went to
McDonald's KFC and then I think we went
to Randy's Donuts huge mistake we get
stuck with luckily it was half a dozen
but they were like massive yeah yeah
massive donuts and one of them was this
horrendous apple fritter I had to get
out and puke like just Auto puke like I
can do I don't pull trigger though I
don't have to put my fingers in my
throat I can just puke I could do it
right now just sitting here this is Cody
coming out of a restaurant
I do not feel good that
I don't know that's kind of weird hold
on
and then everyone's like I I
is lean forward a little bit and then I
can and then here's the most disgusting
part
he goes over here and he just goes
he's wiping his lips and you're like
what and you're like I just threw up
real quick